00:00 Sarah Crespi: This week's episode is
brought to you in part by Atlassian's OpsGenie.
Incidents happen.
Thankfully, OpsGenie empowers Dev and Ops
teams to plan for service disruptions and
stay in control during incidents.
It also gives teams the power to respond quickly
and efficiently to unplanned issues, and helps
to notify all the right people through a smart
combination of scheduling and escalation paths.
With OpsGenie, your next incident doesn't
stand a chance.
Visit OpsGenie.com to sign up to get a free
company account and to add up to five team
members.
That's opsgenie.com, O-P-S-G-E-N-I-E dot com.
Never miss a critical alert again with OpsGenie.
[music]
00:46 SC: Welcome to the Science Podcast for
December 21st, 2018.
I'm Sarah Crespi.
This is the last podcast of the year, and
we're gonna celebrate with a round-up of the
top online news stories, according to David
Grimm, and we'll hear from news editor Tim
Appenzeller.
He talks with Meagan Cantwell about this year's
breakthrough of the year, and some of the
runners-up and break-downs.
And finally, we'll have a look back at the
year in books with Jen Golbeck, our books
host, and science books editor, Valerie Thompson.
01:19 SC: First up today, we have David Grimm,
the online news editor for Science.
Hi, Dave.
01:24 David Grimm: Hey, Sarah.
01:25 SC: So, you're bringing us some of the
top 10 online news stories for the year.
01:29 DG: That's right.
We have a top 10 list, but unlike other science
news top 10 lists, we tend not to focus on
the most important science of the year.
We sort of leave that for our Breakthrough
of the Year issue.
We sort of focus on our favorite stories of
the year.
01:46 SC: Yeah.
01:46 DG: And that's our sort of mix of our
personal favorites as staff, but also the
stories that did very well, traffic or otherwise,
or the stories that were...
01:53 SC: The audience favorites.
01:54 DG: Audience favorites, exactly, yeah.
01:56 SC: Okay, so what was your favorite?
You had a big hand in picking these.
What's your favorite story of the year?
02:01 DG: Well, you know, I think it was probably
this one.
It's a really fun story.
It's about the longest straight-line journey
on earth.
And so, it's actually a water journey.
So the question is if you had a boat, and
say you didn't have a steering wheel on your
boat, and you wanted to be on your boat for
a very long time, what is the path that you
could take that would put you on the longest
straight journey on earth that you would never
have to turn the wheel, that you could just
keep on going in a straight line for what
felt like forever?
02:27 SC: And this is a question that originated
on Reddit, and then who figured out the answer?
02:33 DG: Well, that's the other fun thing
about this story.
This is not a very traditional study for us.
There wasn't like a bunch of scientists coming
up with a research project and getting funding,
and then it took years and years and years.
This actually started as a Reddit post a few
years ago.
Somebody had seen a post on Wikipedia about
what might be the longest straight line on
Earth.
So he decided to post what he thought it was,
and then a couple of scientists saw the post,
and they said, "Well, we can go ahead and
try to prove this.
We can use geometry and all these very complicated,
high-detailed maps of Earth."
And that's what they went ahead and they did.
And they found this path that basically goes
from Southern Pakistan to Northern Russia,
that would yield a trip of about 32,000 kilometers.
03:13 SC: Wow.
Time to just get in your sailboat, Dave.
03:17 DG: That's right.
[laughter]
03:19 SC: Now let's talk about one that had
good numbers.
A story that performed really well, and for
good reason.
It's also a really interesting story.
I'm talking about the pelvis story.
03:30 DG: That's right.
This was one of our most popular stories of
the year, and it has to do with something
called the obstetrical dilemma.
And this is this sort of long-held evolutionary
theory that the woman's pelvis has to be kind
of this...
It's kind of a tug of war between two evolutionary
forces.
It can't be too wide, which would make childbirth
very easy, but it would make walking very
difficult.
And obviously, it can't be too narrow for
the opposite reasons.
Because of that, researchers have long assumed
that all pelvis shapes around the world must
be pretty similar because they have to kind
of deal with the same...
04:05 SC: Forces.
04:06 DG: Forces, right?
04:07 SC: Yeah.
04:07 DG: And that's not what they found.
In fact, they kind of found the opposite.
These researchers looked at 348 female pelvises
from around the world, from 24 different parts
of the world, and what they found was that
these birth canals were far from carbon copies
of each other.
There was a lot of variation, and certain
regions tended to have certain shapes that
other regions didn't, and so that really says
that it must not be evolutionary forces that
are sort of shaping these passages.
04:33 SC: Or the ones that we thought.
04:34 DG: Or the ones that we thought.
It must be some other factors that are playing
a role.
04:39 SC: That means we're going back to the
drawing board, understanding pelvis evolution?
04:42 DG: It does, but it also has some interesting
implications for childbirth, because when
we're trying to figure out how the baby moves
through the birth canal and things like that,
it may actually inform practices around childbirth,
so it's not just kind of an interesting story,
there may actually be some real-world applications
as well.
04:58 SC: Okay.
Now let's talk about...
I don't know that this is my favorite, but
I just...
Watching this story coming together was so
interesting.
This is the first video of living anglerfish
mating.
What does it look like, Dave?
05:12 DG: Right.
Anglerfish are these really, really weird
fish.
They're really creepy, they live really deep
in the ocean, and scientists know almost nothing
about them.
And that's because it's really hard to get
not even a video, but even a photograph of
these guys when they're alive.
If you bring up them to the surface, they
can't deal with the change of pressure, and
it's a really...
It's kind of a disaster.
And so, what's really cool about this is is
it was an exclusive that we had, and we always
love exclusives.
This is the first video taken of anglerfish
mating.
And it's just sort of as bizarre as the fish
themselves.
The scientists captured this large female,
and she's got this much smaller male, or they
call it a dwarf male, that's literally attached
to...
Permanently attached to her body, and he sort
of functions as this sperm sac, essentially.
So what happens, what they think when anglerfish
mate, is the male attaches to the female and
actually becomes part of the female.
He sort of grows into her and almost becomes
like a part of her body.
06:10 SC: So she's supplying him with nutrients.
06:12 DG: Right.
06:13 SC: She's eating food, he can't eat
food anymore.
06:14 DG: Can't do anything, basically.
06:15 SC: But he does supply sperm...
06:17 DG: Right.
06:17 SC: That she can then lay fertile eggs.
06:19 DG: Right.
And then there's this amazing video that researchers
captured with this deep-sea submersible that
showed all this, and it became...
Was it our most popular?
06:27 SC: Oh, absolutely.
06:28 DG: By far most popular video of the
year.
And if you take a look at it, it's not hard
to see why.
06:31 SC: And the quality really...
It's well lit.
A lot of people say that it looks like it's
CGI.
06:37 DG: Oh, really?
[laughter]
06:38 SC: It's just so crystal clear, which
is very unexpected.
Most of the anglerfish photos or anglerfish
corpses...
06:45 DG: Yeah.
06:46 SC: That you see are pretty tattered,
in bad shape, so this is just really amazing.
06:50 DG: Yes.
06:51 SC: Let's finish out the ones that we're
gonna talk about.
We're not gonna list them all out here today.
This one is about tiny quantum engines.
Why did this make the cut?
07:02 DG: Well, I feel like every year we've
got a quantum physics story on our list because,
first of all, we do a lot of quantum physics
stories that others don't, so these tend to
be kind of exclusives for us, which I just
said we like a lot.
07:14 SC: Yeah.
07:14 DG: But they're also just...
The quantum realm is such a bizarre realm
and this is another example of it.
This is this really weird property of quantum
physics that when you try to measure something
at the quantum level, you actually change
it.
You change its position, its distribution,
and in this news day, researchers found that
they could actually harness this change to
create energy, or to create an engine that
would operate with near 100% efficiency.
07:39 SC: Okay, how big is this engine?
07:41 DG: And I should back up and say they
actually didn't create this.
07:43 SC: Okay.
07:43 DG: They actually theoretically created
it.
They said it's theoretically possible.
07:46 SC: They modeled it, okay.
07:47 DG: And these engines are very, very
small.
This would be like the engine the size of
an atom or a molecule.
07:52 SC: Okay.
07:53 DG: So it's not something you would
necessarily put in your car, but this efficiency
is amazing, though.
It's theoretical, when you think of a car,
the engine's about 25% efficient.
08:04 SC: Right.
08:04 DG: So if you've got something that's
100% efficient, you can imagine that you could
create these really, maybe, swarm of tiny,
tiny molecular machines.
Now, the big question is what would you use
them for?
08:16 SC: Right.
08:16 DG: And really, how hard would it be
to create these things in real life?
But just the science around this, the physics
around this is really, really fascinating
to dig into to figure out how something like
this would even be possible in the first place.
08:27 SC: Okay, Dave.
And as I mentioned, we're not gonna reveal
the rest of the top 10, so please go to the
site.
08:32 DG: Including our most popular story
of the year.
08:34 SC: Oh, including the most popular.
[chuckle] But one thing that struck me, looking
at this list, is what is not there, and that
is a cat story, or a dog story, which is just
shocking.
We had a pretty popular story on Viking cats.
Why didn't that make the cut?
08:51 DG: [chuckle] Yeah, just like we have
a quantum physics story every year, I feel
like we've got a cat or a dog story every
year just because I personally love those
stories.
Also, those stories tend to do very well.
Last week we had a story about Viking cats,
and this was another exclusive for us.
This is a story about how cats seem to have
changed size, gotten bigger during the Viking
era, and this was an analysis of a bunch of
cat bones that were found.
Some of these cats were skinned for their
fur.
09:15 SC: Oh.
09:16 DG: And so there's a lot of interesting
history here, too.
This story actually ended up being a lot of
fun, it became very popular, but all of that
was sort of happening while we were putting
together a top 10 list...
09:26 SC: So bad timing.
09:26 DG: So it didn't quite squeak in there,
but it's a story that was a lot of fun and
I highly encourage listeners to go check it.
09:32 SC: And I'm gonna expect at least one
cat or dog story next year in the top 10.
09:35 DG: I hope so, I hope so.
09:36 SC: Alright, thank you so much, Dave.
09:37 DG: Thanks, Sarah.
09:38 SC: David Grimm is the online news editor
for Science.
Read the rest of the top online news stories
at news.sciencemag.org.
Stay tuned for Meagan Cantwell's interview
with news editor Tim Appenzeller on this year's
breakthrough of the year.
[music]
09:58 SC: This week's episode is brought to
you in part by Atlassian's OpsGenie.
Incidents happen, and they require complex
coordination between operations and software
development teams who are putting out fires
everyday.
That's why getting alerts immediately is critical.
Thankfully, there's OpsGenie by Atlassian.
OpsGenie empowers Dev and Ops teams to plan
for service disruptions and stay in control
during incidents.
It also gives teams the power to respond quickly
and efficiently to unplanned issues, and helps
to notify all the right people through a smart
combination of scheduling and escalation paths
that account for things like time zones, holidays.
Better yet, OpsGenie allows for deep flexibility
in how, when, and where alerts are deployed,
with over 200 integrations, like JIRA, Amazon
Cloud Watch, Data Dog, New Relic, and more.
Plus, it tracks all activity and provides
useful insights to improve future incident
responses.
With OpsGenie, your next incident doesn't
stand a chance.
Visit OpsGenie.com to sign up to get a free
company account and add up to five team members.
That's opsgenie.com, O-P-S-G-E-N-I-E dot com.
Never miss a critical alert again with OpsGenie.
[music]
11:13 Meagan Cantwell: Several months ago,
science compiled an extensive list of significant
discoveries and advancements that have occurred
throughout 2018.
Ultimately, that list was whittled down to
a short list of nine runners-up and one winner:
The Breakthrough of the Year.
I'm here with News Editor of Science, Tim
Appenzeller, to talk through a few of these
advancements.
Hey Tim.
11:37 Tim Appenzeller: Hey Meagan.
11:38 MC: Let's get started with one of the
runners-up, which was that the first RNA interference,
or RNAI drug, entered the market this year.
How exactly does this drug treat diseases?
11:51 TA: Well, what it does is it blocks
the genetic message from the gene to the cell's
protein-making machinery, so it actually gets
right at the root of the disease process.
12:00 MC: RNAI was discovered 20 years ago,
but it took a while for it to reach the market.
12:05 TA: Well, it works through small RNAs
that trigger the breakdown of this message
that I mentioned.
And the problem was getting those small RNAs
to the right spot in the body.
12:16 MC: So in the future, we could probably
see other diseases that it's marketed for
as well?
12:20 TA: I think we'll see more drugs following
the same approach, yes.
12:23 MC: Another one on the list was gains
for the Me Too movement within the sciences.
And what changes were catalyzed within science
organizations and research institutions as
a result of this movement?
12:33 TA: Well, several big science organizations
began developing, or at least talking about
mechanisms to take away honors from people
who have been found guilty of sexual harassment.
So this is the kind of thing that the Me Too
movement has been pushing for for some time.
Now, it appears to be starting to happen.
12:52 MC: One of my personal favorites was
the discovery of a 31-kilometer wide impact
crater under Greenland, but they're not sure
exactly when it hit.
It could have a range of anywhere between
12,000 to 100,000 years ago.
When it hit, what would have been the implications
for the climate and life on Earth at that
moment?
13:09 TA: Well, it would have melted an awful
lot of ice, and if this had happened at the
key moment about 13,000 years ago, it could
have caused the climate event called the Younger
Dryas, when the world, which was warming after
the end of the last Ice-age, suddenly returned
to glacial conditions.
And the trigger of this has been a mystery.
This crater raises the possibility that the
impact, if it happened 13,000 years ago, could
have unleashed this flood into the North Atlantic,
which would have shut down a set of currents
and triggered the climate shift.
13:39 MC: So scientists' Breakthrough of the
Year in 2016 was the detection of gravitational
waves, a messenger from a distant universe,
and one of the runners-up from this year is
related to that discovery.
A new type of messenger, neutrinos, were detected
deep in the ice of the South Pole.
What are these particles, and where did they
come from?
14:02 TA: These are very lightweight particles
that are really hard to detect, but they've
set up this detector, which is basically a
cubic kilometer of ice threaded with light
detectors.
It's very clear ice, and so when a neutrino
flies through it, it can sometimes trigger
a faint flash of light, and from the direction
of this flash, they can figure out where the
neutrino came from.
This year, they traced one neutrino back to
a blazar, which is a kind of very bright galaxy
with a black hole at it's center.
It's the first neutrino to be traced to this
kind of source outside our galaxy, and it
suggests that these blazars might be the source
of other high-energy particles, like the high-energy
cosmic rays that sometimes strike the earth.
14:47 MC: Now, moving past these runners up
to the Breakthrough of The Year, which was
development cell by cell.
And being able to observe cell development
wasn't just one discovery necessarily, but
a combination of technologies working together.
Could you explain what advances are encompassed
within this one breakthrough?
15:04 TA: It's really three techniques.
First, the ability to extract thousands of
cells from a developing embryo, then the ability
to sequence their RNA, which tells you what
genes are active cell by cell, You can get
basically the genetic activity in each cell.
And then there are techniques for tracing
cell lineages within embryos, so the RNA sequencing
gives you a snapshot of what's going on in
an embryo.
If you can trace each cell's descendants,
you can see where that type of cell, how it
contributes to the building of the embryo.
So you put it all together and you get this
picture in space and time of how each cell
kind of assumes its identity and gives rise
to new cells to build an embryo.
15:51 MC: What organisms and organs development
were researchers able to see through these
techniques?
15:56 TA: Well, they've looked at a bunch
of them.
The big advance this year was moving these
techniques into vertebrates, animals like
ourselves, really; zebrafish, salamander limbs,
and several others.
16:09 MC: Besides tracking development, what
were other ways that researchers used single-cell
RNA sequencing?
16:15 TA: It's revealed things about development
of disease.
You can look at tissues, you can identify
the variety of cells that make up those tissues,
and you can watch cells change as a disease
develops, for example, a cancer.
16:30 MC: What do you think we can expect
to see in the future as a result of this breakthrough?
16:34 TA: Well, I think deeper understanding
of the way organisms develop, the way limbs
grow, and the way diseases develop, and that,
undoubtedly, will lead to medical treatments.
16:46 MC: Although we had these breakthroughs
of the year, we also had break-downs.
Could you go over what that means?
16:53 TA: Well, these are science-related
developments that are not good.
16:57 MC: [chuckle] Yeah.
16:58 TA: That really were steps back.
We think of science as a march of progress.
Well, it isn't always, and so our major breakdown
of the year was really the gap between what
science is telling us about climate change
and the urgency of it, and what policy makers
are doing or not doing.
17:17 MC: One kind of related advancement,
that would be the attribution science, made
gains this year though, right?
17:22 TA: That's right.
Yeah, yeah.
No, we see more clearly than ever that climate
change is taking place, and that it is getting
worse fast, and that it is affecting the world
we live in in very powerful ways.
The succession of powerful hurricanes, fires
in California, heat waves in far northern
latitudes.
All of these can be tied, to greater or lesser
extent, to climate change.
17:46 MC: Were there any other breakdowns
included in the list?
17:48 TA: Yes.
Late in the year, there was the claim that
an embryo had been genetically modified and
then implanted and brought to term.
So, babies have been born that have been genetically
modified in ways that they will pass on to
their children.
And this happened without the kind of debate,
and without the kinds of safeguards that most
scientists and ethicists believe are necessary,
and without proper consideration of the health
risks to these children.
18:17 MC: Alright, thank you so much, Tim.
18:18 TA: You're welcome, pleasure.
18:19 MC: That was Tim Appenzeller, news editor
of Science.
If you wanna read more about the Breakthrough
of 2018, the runners-up, and the breakdowns
of the year, visit sciencemag.org/news.
18:34 SC: Keep listening for our roundup of
the year in books and some suggestions for
books that you might want to buy as gifts
for the holiday season.
[music]
18:44 Jen Golbeck: Hi everyone.
Welcome to the book segment of the podcast.
This is Jen Golbeck and we're doing the year
in review.
I'm here with Valerie Thompson and we're gonna
talk about our favorite books, and maybe our
least favorite books.
That would be easier if we had a couple cocktails,
I suppose.
Things we remembered, and give you some recommendations
if you're looking for last-minute holiday
gifts.
19:02 Valerie Thompson: So Jen, you interviewed
11 authors for us this year in 2018.
One of them I'm thinking of is especially
timely here at the end of the year.
Do you wanna talk about that one?
19:13 JG: Yeah, so we did The Perfectionist,
by Simon Winchester, who is just a wonderful
interview, a charming guy who's written a
lot of great books, and we had a really long
conversation.
And I think part of it that didn't make it
into his segment on the podcast, this year
is the end of the kilogram being defined by
that lump of metal that I think is in France,
and that's an example of this really precision
engineering, and we're getting rid of that
and replacing it with a much more accurate
and scientific definition.
But he talked about how there's something
a little sad in us as humans not being able
to make that referenced kilogram anymore.
I thought that that was interesting.
I'd forgotten he said that, and then in the
news, just in the last few weeks, we heard
the kilogram is going away and you see this
beautiful little kilogram, it's gonna be locked
into a museum and not worth anything anymore,
and and that that was a nice tie back to his
book on how we can create these very finely-milled
things, and how beautiful human precision
could be.
20:09 VT: I love that.
I love that because it's just this kind of
human story behind this very precise, surreal
kind of thing.
Alright, so can you talk about...
Did any of the books really draw you in?
Was there any that was on a specific topic
that you were really intrigued by?
20:25 JG: Yeah, we did Clean Meat by Paul
Shapiro, which is about lab-grown meat, and
I was really excited when you gave me this
book, because I'm a vegetarian and...
20:35 VT: Me too.
20:35 JG: Oh, alright.
It was really interesting to look at how is
that industry going?
It's much farther along than I thought it
was.
And also talking about what are the ways that
we can get people to do this?
One of the examples he said is that a lot
of people are gonna be skeezed out eating
meat that was grown in a lab, but leather
would be a really interesting way to do this.
Skin is very easy to grow, relatively, even
if you're growing it in a lab.
There we could replace the leather that we're
using that's coming from animals and replace
it with something grown in a lab.
That's not the end game.
We wanna replace the whole animal needing
to be killed.
But it was really interesting because it brought
together this kind of commercialization and
human component of it, in addition to all
the other stuff.
So I thought it was really interesting.
You also have a favorite book this year?
21:22 VT: I do have a favorite book.
The book that was kind of my favorite book
that we reviewed, not on the podcast, but
in the magazine, is a book called The Feather
Thief: Beauty, Obsession, and the Natural
History Heist of the Century, by Kirk Wallace
Johnson.
The book is centered around a theft that occurred
at a natural history museum in the UK in 2009.
In the early hours of June 23rd, a man named
Edwin Rist broke into the Natural History
Museum at Tring and filled a roller suitcase
with 299 bird specimens.
21:54 VT: As the story comes out, we learn
that he is a member of an elite community
of Victorian fly tyers, flies being the brightly-colored
lures that people use to catch fish.
And his plan was to dismantle these bird specimens
and sell the feathers to other fly-tying enthusiasts
so that he could buy a new flute.
Because, did I mention that he was a flautist
who had earlier that day performed at the
London Royal Academy of Music?
22:22 JG: This just gets more insane the more
you talk about it.
22:25 VT: Yeah, it's like a crazy story.
So, he ends up getting caught, and instead
of getting this money for a new flute, he
ends up being sentenced to 12 months in prison
and he receives a fine.
22:37 JG: What happened to the birds?
22:38 VT: Well, that's the thing.
Once these specimen were removed from the
museum, and once they were separated from
the little tags that are on them that tell
you what the specimen is and when it was collected
and by whom, they don't have any more scientific
value, so even the specimens that were recovered,
those lose their value.
A lot of them were dismantled.
Just the agony of what has been lost to science,
and so it's a really interesting...
I think I'm kind of like a true crime person
too, so this is why that story really resonates
with me, I think.
23:10 JG: It sounds fantastic.
So, recommendations, woman with the shelves
and shelves full of books?
23:16 VT: Okay, I'm gonna recommend Phillip
Moriarty's When the Uncertainty Principle
Goes to 11, or How to Explain Quantum Physics
With Heavy Metal.
It's a great premise.
The idea is that music is an ideal platform
for introducing concepts like the physics
of waves and harmonics and resonance and energy
conservation, and he kind of does these cute
analogies where he shows how physics' famous
double-slit experiment and Eddie Van Halen's
Brown Sound both share this key feature, which
is waveform interference.
He looks at the statistical mechanisms of
crowds in a mosh pit, he compares the sound
of the Big Bang with the loudest heavy-metal
concert, so, very fun.
23:58 VT: Physics is not my strong suit, so
I'm always kind of on the hunt for things
that can lead me to it slowly, I guess.
[laughter] So I thought this book was really
fun.
For the politically-minded in the audience,
I'm going to recommend Lilliana Mason's Uncivil
Agreement: How politics became our identity.
So this is a very kind of relevant one for
our time.
It looks at how political polarization became
such a prominent feature of our political
system.
She kind of argues that there's become more
and more overlap between our other identities,
so a person's race, their religious affiliation,
whether they think of themselves as liberal
or conservative, and then whether we consider
ourselves to be a Democrat or Republican.
And so, when we start identifying psychologically
with a particular party, we start to experience
this animosity towards the other team and
a desire for our own team to win, which becomes
an end unto itself, even if we don't have
particularly strong feelings for the issue.
It's a really interesting look at this thing
that we're all kind of wondering about.
And she does have some ideas for how we might
try to mitigate those.
25:07 JG: Oh, that's good.
25:08 VT: Yeah.
25:08 JG: I hope that works.
[laughter]
25:09 VT: Yeah, I hope so too.
I hope somebody them to heart.
You had a recommendation for a gift this year,
too.
25:16 JG: I love to do combination gifts.
And I think we talked about that when we did
our year in the review last year, where I
think we had a wine book and I'm like, "Oh,
it'd be great, you give a bottle of wine,
and then this book."
This year, I recommend you get a bottle of
Lysol disinfectant, and then this book, Never
Home Alone, From Microbes to Millipedes, Camel
Crickets and Honey Bees: The Natural History
of Where We Live, by Rob Dunn.
This a book that I got sent from the publisher.
I just looked it up on Amazon today, it's
the number one best seller in ichthyology
on Amazon, which is a pretty cool distinction.
But it's sort of about how we aspire to have
these super clean, pristine, homes and how
they're totally not, and there's all of these
bugs and organisms and stuff living in there
with us.
26:03 JG: One of my favorite examples from
it that it I think opens with towards the
beginning, is talking about this research
lab where they're looking at these organisms
that live in thermal vents, these super-high
temperatures, and how we've never really been
able to find them before because our regular
lab temperatures are so cold.
Even our hot lab temperatures are so cold
that they couldn't live, and then you'd put
them at these hot temperatures and oh, they
were there, and then we started learning about
them.
And in the lab, they're like, "Maybe they're
actually all over the place, and not just
in these thermal vents," and started looking
at their coffee pot, which didn't have any,
but other places where there's hot water,
and they found them there.
26:38 JG: So there actually are these what
seemed like really exotic organisms, they're
in these thermal vents, but actually, they
live in all these crazy environments that
we create in these small places around where
we live, and talks about how our weird household
obsessions actually can kind of drive evolution
in some of these micro-organisms.
But yeah, that'd make a nice gift with some
Raid, or some Lysol, [laughter] just is a
nice little joke...
27:02 VT: I don't know, is that embracing
or rejecting the premise of the book?
[laughter] This is Jen's last episode as our
host.
She's been hosting the segment for us for
the last two years.
So I just wanna say thank you on behalf of
all of us at Science.
It's been great to work with you, I've loved
listening to your interviews.
You've done a great job and we're really gonna
miss you.
27:26 JG: I've had a super-fun time.
I love that I now have a couple shelves of
books that I've reviewed for Science, and
as a fiction reader by choice, it has been
a really great opportunity to find the best
new science books that are out there, and
then also get to have my own personal conversations
with the people who are writing them.
I've had a great time.
27:45 VT: Great.
I'm glad we converted you.
27:47 JG: Yeah, you did.
I'm now reading all sorts of new ones.
[chuckle]
27:50 VT: Alright, great.
27:51 JG: Thanks everyone.
Have a very merry Christmas and happy Hanukkah,
and happy New Year, and happy holidays, and
all those things.
And someone else will be back with you in
the new year with more books.
[music]
28:06 SC: Just a reminder that this episode
has been brought to you in part by Atlassian's
OpsGenie.
Incidents happen.
Thankfully, OpsGenie empowers Dev and Ops
teams to plan for service disruptions and
stay in control during incidents.
It also gives teams the power to respond quickly
and efficiently to unplanned issues, and helps
to notify all the right people through a smart
combination of scheduling and escalation paths.
With OpsGenie, your next incident doesn't
stand a chance.
Visit opsgenie.com to sign up to get a free
company account and add up to five team members.
That's O-P-S-G-E-N-I-E dot com, opsgenie.com.
Never miss a critical alert again with OpsGenie.
[music]
28:48 SC: And that concludes this edition
of the Science Podcast.
If you have any comments or suggestions for
the show, write to us at Science podcast at
AAAS.org.
You can subscribe to the show anywhere you
get your podcast, or you can listen on the
Science website.
That's sciencemag.org/podcast.
To place an ad on the podcast, contact midroll.com.
This show was produced by Sarah Crespi and
Meagan Cantwell, and edited by Podigy.
Jeffrey Cook composed the music.
On behalf of Science Magazine and its publisher,
AAAS, thanks for joining us.